hey guys I think I'm back again this
time to make another crazy cool desert
thing I was just scrolling through my
Instagram and I found this really cool
flower looking cake think of like a
raindrop cake but with a rose inside it
looks really complicated so I thought
why not try and make it myself what I
did find was an online tutorial by
gelatin art market I will work really
hard and try and try and try again until
I make it happen so let's get started
for the gelatin base there's a couple
things we need gelatin powder this one
says super clear citric acid lots of
sugar water quavering I chose lemon I
think go add like a nice citrus touch
three tablespoons of gelatin and one cup
of cold water and then just mix it I'm
gonna stir this until there's no more
clumps left
oh I'm gonna put that aside we're gonna
start boiling the water and sugar 3 cups
of water nobody felt tasty okay 2 cups
of sugar 1 teaspoon of citric acid turn
it on get a spoon and stir it until the
sugar dissolves gelatin in the meanwhile
it is now quite firm once I see steam
I'm supposed to stop oh there is steam
we have our beautiful gelatin here it is
now completely in solid form throw it in
there now we're just stirring that
together add a little bit of flavoring
this is pretty much done so I let it
cool for a little bit we're just gonna
pour it into these little containers
that I buy in order to have enough
backup if I screw up tomorrow I'm gonna
make a lot just just to be safe
I'm gonna wrap these up and put it in
the fridge and we'll be back tomorrow
for the really really hard part until
then I'm gonna get a good night's sleep
and see y'all tomorrow it is now the
second day and we are back here to check
on the gelatin I pulled them out from
the fridge and guess what it's not
falling out it looks clear which is what
you want for a base I also made this
huge tub of gelatin just for practice so
let's go into the color making segment
we'll see how the rest of this goes I
don't like what we did with the gelatin
base I need one tablespoon of gelatin
powder now we need three tablespoons of
cold water we're gonna throw in the
sugar the milk let it heat up so now we
have the heated milk and sugar looks a
little translucent I'm gonna put the
jelous in and out and slowly melt it
down add the remaining half cup of cold
milk we have to add the white food
coloring makes it appear less
translucent we're supposed to blend this
in this is work it does work put this in
a good idea oh my god oh yeah okay I
think we have the color base so I have a
couple of bottles of food coloring here
just went with some classic flower
colors waiting for it in case I feel
ambitious enough to make leaps it's just
like working with frosting we have our
color palette ready not sure if the
consistency is right yet but we're
moving forwards let's get to flour
making I have and gelatin art tools
which are supposed to help me because
they're already shaped like petals but
we're gonna start off using this all
right that's color I'm gonna need some
tissue oh my god that looks like blood
this is not a good color to start with
okay really bad choice of color the idea
was to poke this in and then this color
is terrifying me but look so that's kind
of what we're going for
I know how do you do this the gelatin is
working the color is working it's just
that my hands aren't working I look like
I just killed somebody let's try that
again
how am I supposed to draw a petal I
guess that could be a cool design that
looks like a cool flower I didn't even
do that though I don't know how I did it
hold on I need to do some retraining
really quick
oh they're holding it like this oh it
looks better no I broke it I got a
little so excited I just have these like
deformed petals in this little tub I
should have made a bigger tub didn't I
try using this plug it into this these
tools are supposed to help you so I'm
hoping this will actually make it look
more like a flower okay this is so much
easier than a needle we're gonna test it
out on one of the other practice little
bowls I made so here we have your bowl
we're gonna put this in I'm just gonna
keep going
I'm getting color all over my hands how
does that look that's a little baby
flower you guys it looks good right
this makes me feel really good I'm gonna
try and take it out let me just warm it
up a little this is supposed to be the
method to take it out oh my god
flip it yes look at that I know it's not
much but we went from this to this
so I'm pretty pretty happy right now I'm
so excited
think we can make this work let's try
working on a second one around - let's
do it I'm gonna start off with actually
this a flower center well I can feel
like adrenaline pumping through my veins
oh yes got the center in which one looks
most like a rose please don't mess this
up with this here
PC add like a little rose petal
I have little gelatin bits not a good
sign I'm just supposed to build around
this right Oh looking good so far I'm so
nervous
oh no I added too much color it's okay
it's okay it's okay it's okay
refill my god oh my god shaking I'm just
gonna concentrate not talk for a bit try
to get this to work this is so
nerve-racking this is what it looks like
so far I don't know how I got to this
point it looks like a real rose and even
has like random spots on it that makes
it look more real I was so surprised oh
no it's coagulating this is what happens
when it sits here for a while it becomes
clumpy that splotch was great that's
what I'm trying to put them in like this
pan of water so then I can control their
consistency they were saying this is the
best way to warm it up heating reheating
preheating nice let's get back to
business
oh no I tore it I tore the gelatin so
that is my cue to stop should we flip it
what if I can't get it out here we go oh
that was anti-climatic all right in the
beginning it looked really good and then
as I moved outwards it just became worse
and worse but I think for a second
attempt this still looks really cool
we're getting somewhere
can I keep going it kind of made a rose
I know we could do one that's better but
I wanted to try something different I
don't want to mess around with the white
and yellow make like a daisy but not
really wants to do this just right in
the middle oh my god can chill out so
nervous do I know what I'm doing no I'm
just trying to be creative it looks
pretty cool changing colors to white oh
let's do it
[Music]
holy moly a preview of what is about to
come this takes time and patience all of
the stuff that I have limited amounts of
oh my god Oh cold sweat once you get
going there's no stopping Oh
more and more we're getting there I
think slowly but surely let's go for
another layer so far this is what we
have I really want this to work
it has to work just keep going just keep
going
ready tada I'm just gonna add some
leaves it's a little ambitious I'm a
completely mess up the whole thing but
if this works this is gonna be magical
that is not the sound of success
please don't mess up here goes nothing
[Music]
looks like I don't have on but hold on I
think we can make this work
subconsciously holding my breath one
more leaf oh my god here it is this is
what it looks like with the leaves I'm
gonna try and cover the base of white
this is supposed to help the color pop
I'm nervous oh my god I'm gonna put this
in the fridge and we'll check on it in a
bit moment of truth the white color base
has set we're gonna try and flip this
around this is going to be the ultimate
flower I'm so nervous
if this messes up I want him to do it
all over again I don't want to rush it
this really No Oh ready you guys
how's that look it looks pretty legit I
really did not think I would be able to
do this
I am super happy right now give me one
second all right
I have all the flowers I made it looks
like a little garden really not the
easiest things to make it's been a
roller coaster ride would I eat it I'm
gonna eat one right now here you go this
is what it looks like it's a little bit
jiggly would taste like lime jell-o let
me know what you guys think if you think
I did a good job what else you guys want
me to make Anna I see y'all next time
I'm gonna slowly walk away from this
[Music]